I'm always curious man being uh gay in
the hip-hop industry yeah it's obviously
a very homophobic uh genre of music
historically yeah because the rapper
sucking dick ain't gonna tell you
they're not gonna tell you that these
[__] out here sucking dick [__]
trans they're not gonna tell you these
[__] out here [__] and you
know what they never really [__] with me
because one I think I mean of course I'm
cute I'm well dressed I'm rich and by
the way you're 45 and you're you're 45.
black don't crack God bless crack when
you're broke okay black don't crack when
you got a good dermatologist well you
look great thank you but the thing about
it is I mean my career is [__] off my
dating opportunity in the hip-hop
Community because these [__] Ain't
Gonna slide them ideas because they know
like or they don't know they assume that
I'm gonna put them on blast which if
they follow me I don't out people I
don't attack children and you know um
there's one more thing I can't think of
but you know there's just some certain
things that I don't do but
um I know that a lot of reasons why some
of these hip-hop artists don't call my
show is they have skeletons and they
think that if they sit in that chair I'm
going to throw them out I would never
out them you know but I also feel like
they've never outright disrespecting me
for being gay because you know you throw
some [__] at me I'm a no pun intended
I'm gonna throw some [__] at you
um but I don't really feel like I don't
get disrespected but I do feel like
there's a sense of with some artist
sense of fear to you know come and sit
and talk with me because of what they
think I may say I was gonna say do you
feel like that the like like it feels
like
the homophobia is kind of chilling out a
bit when you got a guy like little Naz X
who's obviously a [__] pop star but
you know I I guys like yourself are do
you feel like the the level of that [__]
is at least kind of like
started to kind of
I will say that I think that mainstream
still uses artists like little nazex or
Saucy Santana to break the barrier by
showing a image of what being black and
gay looks like that's not always what it
looks like right I'm proud of sassy
Santana in his hustle because I've seen
him behind the scenes I went to the
rehearsal with him and Madonna Madonna
invited super nice guy super that but
super professional he's on his [__] like
he really is excited I had like one of
my funniest interviews with him ever
like he was great he's great and Lil Nas
X for him to be able to continue to live
in his truth and do what he's doing I
mean I'm fans of both but I also believe
that like the industry for years has
made the black male the black gay male
experience on TV and in mainstream be an
accessory to a reality star housewife or
a [__] wearing heels and makeup and
that's not all of us like some of us are
just real [__] who grew up in the hood
and who happened to be gay but like who
I'm [__] and who's in my bed should
have no Martin should have no influence
over our relationship because I'm not
trying to [__] half the people that
think I'm trying to [__] them right but
I will say that um I do think it's
getting easier now for people to see us
because the representation is there but
what really makes it easier is when you
see a jack Harlow perform with a little
nice X not when you see Lil Nas X
performing at the BET Awards in front of
the people and then they pan to the
hip-hop artists and they're acting
uncomfortable right when half of your
[__] trans and Men Behind Your Baby
Mama's back
um so that kind of [__] makes me
uncomfortable because I'm like don't
[__] play around don't [__] play
around because what you don't want is
you don't want me to stop wanting to
protect your secrets when I could really
level the playing field and say okay
um so and so you remember my homeboy
such and such and then boom now they on
my show I would never do that but I'm
just saying like I do get frustrated
sometimes when I see certain artists
seemingly uncomfortable when you know we
know if we pulled the curtain back
there's a skirt under there right yeah I
think that like there's a few instances
over the last couple of years where I
was just like like me and boozy talked
like he was on my show and I was trying
to explain to him why he's pretty
homophobic and he just was not agreeing
with me the whole time I want him on my
show that'd be great I'm we're talking
if you that listen I'd pay I'd pay good
money to watch you and I'm working on it
that would be great because I think I
think he you know people meet me and
they have a different experience and it
allows them to be open-minded I don't
know he has put he's been 10 tones down
for what he believes in and I'm ten toes
down for what I believe in but I'm able
to have a conversation where I can help
a person see like you know if you think
about it if you are a woman and you're
homophobic then you're you're you don't
believe in feminist rights of women
having equal pay them in you don't
believe in being able to have the right
to vote you don't believe in any you
know you don't believe in having control
over your bodies if you believe in all
those things then how could you not
believe another Community should have
the same should have the same belief
that they should have those rights too
because it's not going to take away from
what you got right me [__] some dude
ain't gonna doesn't mean I want to [__]
your kid doesn't mean I want to [__]
your husband we're not pedophiles but
we're just in our community so what is
it that makes you uncomfortable about
what we're doing when it has no effect
on what you're doing now if you say oh
well my kids have to see it your kids
you also paid for your kid to get head
from a woman who gave you head so who
could say that they would pay to get
their dick sucked and then let that same
mouth go suck the dick of their underage
child you can call that what you want
it's strange little strange every
Community has his [__] yeah but you
can't say that's a little strange but
then look at our community and say
that's [__] weird it's all weird if
if weird is weird it's all weird or it's
just your preference in ours we prefer
to do [__] that you don't do you prefer
to do [__] that we don't do but we have
to get to a place where like gay [__]
ain't going nowhere and these these
these these hood [__] who grow up with
whatever they grew up with they they're
not going anywhere so how do we co-exist
in a world where we're not judging each
other and attacking each other but
you're just coexisting yeah I think uh I
think we're getting we'll probably be to
a place in like 20 or 30 years we're
like just like everyone's [__]
everybody it'll be there when me and
Boosie had an interview dude
Boosie is on my short list I I I I
respect them enough to have the dog oh
he's a legend yeah and he's uncancelable
he's like one of the few guys who could
just do anything and it's like his Nick
he's [__] boozy like what do you want
from him my cousin loves Boosie's gonna
boozy Boosie my cousin Anthony from
Stockton he said bro you gotta give this
is like when I wasn't really on Boost
because I at first it was a lot to
digest well listen being from the West
Coast yeah I also I knew about boozy I
knew some of his [__] but then I moved
to Florida and I really saw like oh he's
there Tupac for real really like I moved
to Tampa Florida when he got out of jail
I was living there yeah you'd have
thought like the good loves Jesus got
resurrected out of the [__]
Clearwater Beach ocean like they love
yeah they love me my cousin he he's the
he's the barometer of the boozy and the
NBA young boys and all that world he's
like yo you gotta get Boosie so I'm
working on